a woman freaked out on an American
Airlines flight over the weekend and
since we now live in a culture that
encourages people to film people in
distress rather than to help them the
poor lady has gone viral
I'm telling you I'm getting the off
and there's a reason why I'm getting the
off of everyone can either Believe
it or they cannot believe it I don't
give two but I am telling you right ow
that mother
that back there is not real
and you can sit on this plane and you
can die with them or not I'm not going
to ah so what happened was the woman
having a psychotic break
did she have a few too many drinks at
the airport bar
was her seat mate not real
I don't know it seems unlikely but maybe
Matt's right and she saw an alien or
maybe since Matt is not right maybe she
saw a demon I don't know I don't know
I have very little interest in observing
a woman's apparent meltdown on an
airplane
but I have a great interest in observing
culture and I can't help but notice in
this case how different the reaction is
from the last big viral moment that our
whole culture embraced a couple of
months ago
a vagrant violent criminal with a rap
sheet a mile long a man who had recently
beaten up elderly men and women walked
onto a New York City subway train and
threatened to kill people and our
culture makers our media our political
establishment
they treated that man as the most
innocent downtrodden sympathetic
breakdancer ever to moonwalk onto the F
train
an oppressed black man struck down by
the scourge of white supremacy that
ubiquitous deadly scourge
and then this past weekend a white woman
had an emotional outburst and walked off
an airplane without threatening anyone
and she is now a universal object of
mockery and derision a dumb stupid Karen
who should probably be arrested and put
on some meds
what matters about the airline freakout
video is not whether that lady thought
her seat mate was a real person or not
more significant about the video is
whether the viewers
think the lady freaking out is a real
person herself right now go to
geniusell.com
sold out of their Dark Spot Corrector
and our listeners have been begging for
a restock begging on their hands and
knees well I've got great news just in
time for the summer
gets back geniuselle's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has not won but three Cutting
Edge ingredients and goes to work fast
to Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots and even old discoloration both on
your face and your hands you can now
enjoy your summer sun Beach and
barbecues without embarrassing spots
Virginia sells most popular package also
features their summer Essentials such as
the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun
you'll be amazed how quickly you will
see results or 100 of your money goes
back guaranteed go to genucel.com
Knowles right now
get your dark spot corrector in the
genius almost popular package that is
geniusell.com Knowles right now save
over seventy seven zero percent off
geniusell's most popular package all
orders will include a mystery luxury
gift while supplies last geniusell.com
Knowles when I saw that video I thought
maybe she had a few too many at the
airport
it's happened to the best of us but what
did she see she probably saw something
she she's clearly afraid of something
and because I recognize that there is
spiritual warfare in the world I thought
I don't know maybe I don't know maybe
she saw something that at least
signified or symbolized something that
might be real and genuinely scary and
then my associate producer young Jacob
today was it Mr Davies one of the two of
them
points out that there's a follow-up
video by a guy who says he's the one who
freaked the woman out and the guy turns
out to be a face tattooed Freemason who
called himself Lucifer all right so the
internet has heard the story of the
woman on the plane with the reptilians
but thanks to her delaying the flight I
just got home so now it's my opportunity
to tell my side of the story as the guy
in the hoodie so we're attempting to fly
out of Dallas Fort Worth and then
basically this woman she sits next to me
and she's clearly been drinking I'm
minding my own business and sure enough
she sees my hoodie that has this
Freemason logo on it put a pause right
there I'm just minding my own business
this you know
Ben Shapiro of every observation he's
ever made in his life his best one is
the observation about face tattoo
syndrome which is someone someone
tattoos their whole face they make a
huge spectacle of themselves in a way
that is really spooky and grotesque and
then they just wait for you to notice it
and then they get angry when you notice
it so what are you looking at
what are you looking at oh I don't know
the the attention you demanded that's
what I'm offering you because you've
tattooed your face in a way that is
menacing and spooky and you've got all
these occult symbols all over you and
then you get angry at me for noticing
the thing that you're begging me to
notice keep going
and on top of that she's noticed my ring
so she started to ask questions nothing
dramatic just asked me do I know what
these symbols mean why am I wearing it
what's the purpose yada yada and long
story short I basically just say hey I'm
a Freemason I even briefly explained how
I educate about Freemasonry here on Tick
Tock next thing I know she basically
starts to grill me about low-level
Freemason and that it's all Satanism and
that it's ruled by reptilians and blah
blah blah so I simply put my hood up and
I started to ignore her and basically
just mind my own business she starts
getting louder and louder and then
basically she's like you know that they
worship Lucifer at the top right so I I
looked at her dead in her eyes and I
said I am Lucifer I've heard one
individual laugh behind me so I figured
somebody got a kick out of it at least
she starts running up and down the
aisles freaking out saying I'm a
reptilian and then all this other stuff
she's gonna get off the plane yada yada
it doesn't show all the footage it just
says that she's trying to get off the
plane because of you know I'm not going
to say it here on Tick Tock I don't want
to get banned but then also talking
about how like I'm secretly also trying
to take over the world so I look back at
the guy that was basically chuckling
before and I winked at him so I
basically whispered something under my
breath saying that Freemasons don't care
to rule the world we ruled the universe
and I look back at the guy that was
laughing before and just kind of winked
at him because he started laughing again
well I didn't think that she could hear
me but evidently she did and it is a big
joke further and then they'd like and so
on so forth so immoral of the story
don't believe everything you hear on the
internet
and Freemasons don't care to rule the
world when we rule the universe
so
this was a Twist that not a lot of
people expected the woman especially if
if we're assuming she had a few drinks
at the airport bar
pretty much totally Vindicated right I
think he put yourself in her shoes
and you're sitting there next to a face
tatted up guy who's got a cult symbolism
all over his body who says that he's
Lucifer and controls the Universe I
I think she's pretty Vindicated and
Justified now you might say well he's
just joking
he's just being ironic and
I guess my objection to that point is
I think irony ends once you tattoo your
face I think that's pretty much the end
of irony I've observed on this show
before that if you behave in an ironic
way for your whole life it's no longer
ironic it becomes Earnest because
there's no way to distinguish between
irony and sincerity I think the moment
that tattoo gun hits your face that's
when the irony sees this I think you're
pretty committed to the bid at that
point
and esotericists and hermetic sort of
Cults that worship illumination and all
that sort of thing I don't know if
you're if you're calling if you're
saying that you control the universe and
you got the tats and the symbols I don't
you know
I'm not saying I would have stormed off
the plane I probably just would have
said a couple of prayers you know maybe
talk to the guy figured out what he
actually believes beyond all these kinds
of slogans but maybe if I'd had one or
two too many Rose like that lady perhaps
did
I might have just walked off the plane
too boy what a great clip that was make
sure that you subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel ring that Bell
see you next time